hi reject nation we're gonna capitalize
on all the fun today that's been
happening with the predator 2018 edition
oh man did I have a ball of a time at
the theater I don't know what everyone's
complaining about man this movie is one
of the top 10 best movies of the year
definitely one of the best predator
movies oh yeah just hey we post a lot on
our Stardust app and it's not a
sponsored video because any time you
mention something outside here people
think it's sponsored we just post a lot
over there and we load if you could
follow us so check out our star bus
reaction you see how much we loved the
movie run we walked out it's definitely
different yeah it's definitely different
that doesn't even try to be a horror
movie whatsoever conflict I felt like
the first hour I I enjoyed even though I
was aware that it wasn't great I had a
good time I laughed a lot I enjoy the
gore the last 30 to 40 minutes really
feels like shame blacks giving up on
this movie that but yeah two out of five
I guess yeah let's talk about this movie
I'm not gonna try to sound fancy look
here's a twenty eight Century Fox says
the movies about what a young boy
accidentally triggers the universe's
most lethal hunters to return to Earth
only a ragtag crew of X soldiers and a
disgruntled science teacher it could
prevent the end of the human race yeah
that sounds amazing so many people are
bagging on this movie every review I've
heard is constantly using the word
disappointing which I'm very much
fascinated by that choice of word for
this specific film I love the original
1987 predator movie I think it's a great
action sci-fi film mixed with a lot of
awesome horror elements there's a lot of
greatness to that film I think that
predator movie is great I think the
franchise is not good there's a
difference there it's not like this
movie needs to follow up something
amazing that came before it because it
doesn't come from a line of amazing
films well and the the legacy of the
first predator movie isn't necessarily
due to the fact that it is some
groundbreaking incredible
film it's just really good at being what
it is delivering a very action-packed
and very visceral kind of horror centric
experience for people to say this
movie's disappointing I don't agree with
that choice of words cuz I'm like it's
the predator franchise it would have
been more surprising had it been really
great that does not mean that this film
is necessarily good I don't I wouldn't
say that either nor would I say this
movie is okay I would say what I said on
Twitter it's the most entertaining ly
bad film I've seen in a long time
because I'm sorry I'm sorry here's how
I'll break down my experience with the
film the opening like the prologue to
this movie is so cheesy ly awful but
then it gets into the introduction you
get act 1 with Boyd Holbrook the setup
of the movie which I thought was decent
then you get to act 2 which i think is
very much aware of what this film is
going for it's a cheesy dumb action with
some comedy lines in here that are
genuinely really funny there were a
comedy the comedic moments in any that
are SuperDuper funny and then if you
know how typical Hollywood screenplays
go there's an all's lost moment in these
big Hollywood films which occurs a
little bit before the finale right
around that time is when the movie just
becomes bad it's not even like cheesy
fun bad or aware of how dumb it is and
then when you get to the ending like the
very end of this move it just becomes
lazy and awful it's just awful the last
30 to 40 minutes
it literally is seen black going screw
this I hate all the studio notes let's
just get this over with as a far as
finales go it's one of those where
you're partway through you're like I
know how many things we need to do to
wrap this up and we're not halfway yeah
it gets it gets kind of tedious in the
last half-hour of this film but there's
some movies where you can go you know
the first 2/3 aren't bad it's the third
the last third that's really awful and
sometimes that last third doesn't ruin a
lot of what came before it this movie it
does because of plot points that occur
are revealed
it doesn't affect a lot of that first
2/3 first 2/3 are not great but I think
there
entertaining and I think they're
enjoyable I think they're dumb kind of
schlocky with some shame black comedy
don't really quickly touch on the comedy
part of this there was like three
official trips by me I like the teaser
trailer than two main trailers I'm one
of them at least one of them we had said
that this movie probably has a lot of
comedy that's just not being represented
in the movie it's from Shane black you
keep saying this is a shame blacks movie
where's the shame black humor seems like
there's a personality of these soldiers
that are gonna bring a whole new layer
to this film the trailer is not doing
anything to reflect that none of the
trailers that and almost every review
I'm seeing of this film people are
harping on the fact that this film has
comedy well everyone's calling it a
comedy which led me to go in expecting
it to be like wildly different in tone
than what I actually got yeah even well
yeah there's a lot of humor and anytime
you get a bunch of ragtag mercenaries
together like you're gonna have that in
order you push a blacks they wanted me I
was actually like oh people led me to
believe this would be a lot more wacky
and joke oriented than I thought I mean
there's a lot of scenes where it's very
much like it's out of a comedy
everyone's like surprised by how much
comedy there is shame black I felt like
a predator movie that had a decent
amount of comedy yeah I didn't feel like
a predator comedy to me there's a scene
in uh in a hotel room that I personally
really thought was funny I think goes on
a little too long but I genuinely
laughing and they wanted to make you
laugh but it was really funny you okay
with it going on a little while because
it's one of the better moments in the
movie that's actually fun that you're
actually in super comedic yeah but I
really enjoyed it involves all the
soldiers Thomas Janke eagle Michael key
guy guys penis ripped off a game of
Thrones some Mexican guy you meet
alfalfa Allen or yeah a guy who I
thought was 57 he first showed us but
it's a really funny moment it like the
whole that whole dialogue and Olivia
Munn's the lines are too I think are
super funny but I also think it seems
like that way but people have an issue
the movie yeah yeah I mean it's as in
terms of the proportion of scenes it's
kind of all over the place so in terms
of what this franchise has evolved into
cuz you gotta kind of look at the
as a whole involved it doesn't know
involved with devolve into there's like
no horror in this movie whatsoever
there's there's Gore there's a lot of
gore really it was an awesome gore
there's a lot of gore there's a verily
any suspense there's a lack of tension
for sure it's really just the first
two-thirds are kind of just a fun
enjoyable silly romp I would not say
this movie is boring the characters are
whatever to me in the movie they're a
ragtag bunch of mercenaries you know
there is colorful as you'd expect but
they're not extraordinary in any way I
think if there's one element that I
would say is disappointing to me about
it is the fact that shame blacks
involved and the characters are so
two-dimensional when I feel like what
shame like does so well is character
yeah I feel like this movie has a lot of
Shane black earmarks that just don't get
fleshed or utilized totally at all like
it's weird to look at all these other
movies and then to look at this because
this really does feel like a very
watered down Shane black like Shane
black light is what this movie is to me
it's it's so especially in the last
third of this movie you can feel a lot
of studio notes I felt like it yeah
there's a lot there's a lot there's a
lot of try this out try this out do this
now the trailers reveal a lot I think if
you watch the trailers you can kind of
see how this who's gonna play the part
when the movie really lost me is towards
the finale Anna and I can't go into it
like too much that's spoiling it it's
towards the finale but then I thought
about it today I think when the film
really gets lost is when they introduce
the Upgrade predator
Ultra weather when the predator
storyline really starts to kick in I
iced the movie started to lose me
increasingly yeah because there is a
story going on between the Predators as
well as the story going on between the
predator and the humans this movie
starts off with aware of what it is
cheesiness goofiness fun action into oh
this is just awful now there's this
whole plot line that starts being
introduced with giant predator which is
distracting because the original
predator is all practical and then the
new predator his CGI he has that across
the board because there was one moment
where I was watching and I was like oh
wow really admiring this animatronic
predator head that they had I was like
oh cool like a practical effect and like
some of the gore of X are also practical
but then the other half of everything is
all CG there's some so terrible CG at
moments like flat-out terrible CG yeah
and so like the the predator the the
element we all arguably came to see is
kind of distracting in the bigger
picture yeah because the effects just
aren't consistent with each other
towards the finales when like a lot of
the major complaints I think really
occur terrible storytelling terrible
plot decisions terrible editing there's
like some really bad editing yeah that
affected me for this movie overall
because honestly I thought like the
first third was fine it was like alright
it was a lot of exposition like I said
they're kind of being like I'm used to
better dialog from Shane black
especially with things like this then
the second third is fun I thought was
that was the most fun part is the second
act and then the third part is just a
mess but the whole movie like especially
during the first act I was like this
movie doesn't have rhythm it keeps
moving forward and all the scenes feel
like the same length and then you know
we move on to something else then
there'll be a random like two-shot scene
thrown in and so yeah like the movie
overall stops having a pace and then
when it gets let's put it definitely but
it never stops having energy it's just
weird it's like a drummer who wants to
do a lot of stuff but doesn't have any
sense of timing it was just kind of
hitting all the sound here in taste not
boring
kind of finds a pace for the finale but
then the finale isn't engaging hardly at
all I like the cast I thought like all
the the actors themselves brought an
appropriate amount of yeah melody and I
thought that like Olivia Munn was really
was like legit good in her performance I
thought she was really we're only saying
that because of all the controversy
she's been receiving and we want to
defend woman that was the irony though
actor in this she the characters
whatever but her performance is good yes
she's just very nice kind of goes that
way for most of the cast because all the
characters talk the same I really feel
like a lot of the last third was just
like a giant rewrite and a giant reshoot
yeah it does feel that way a lot of
because everyone's like suddenly there's
a lot of f-bombs in this movie but in
the last like half hour I'm like why is
every sentence have the f-word in it
everyone starts talking the same the
dialogue is at all they all sorts having
the same voice each act feels like it's
out of another movie there's a lot of
plot lines and subplots that are
introduced that I think that if you can
that you could have had a more cohesive
more interesting film if you I think you
should have cut out the whole like giant
predator upgrade thing I thought that
was that really weak in the movie for me
the motivation for most of the predator
stuff is kind of perplexing yeah it's
it's with no explanation it's kind of
yes sterling K Brown was funny and cool
but then in the finale I'm like I guess
this guy I was a lot cooler with that
character before I sort of understand
what he was about and the night I hate
when movies like this try to seem more
important by having commentary on
society like they started going into you
know climate change they go into people
with mental illness with PTSD no
Asperger's a super rats tourettes makes
you funny I hate when movies like this
try to sound more important like out of
nowhere like don't do that I understand
pulling these things to add real-world
details and there are ways to take those
things and to use them to give something
thin a little more dimension but the
weird thing is they do bother to address
so many different mental states for
so many different characters you're like
are you gonna utilize these in any way
shape for are you just kind of trying to
character develop by naming conditions
world cuz the thing to is like in a
movie like this I'm not sitting there
going I'm hoping for great character
arcs but in a movie executed the way
this one is executed if by the end you
realize like nobody grows changes
nothing happens to anyone everyone's
pretty much the same when they're
setting them up especially certain
characters for that when I say it's an
entertaining bad movie it's like this
movie feels like a b-movie to me it's
it's fast paced with two-dimensional
characters with a lot of go works it can
be really funny and amusing at times and
then and then it but then it just gets
horrible yeah and all of its wrapped in
kind of a flat yeah aesthetic like you
know the shots aren't overly amazing in
any direction like weirdly kept thinking
the Meg could have borrowed this tone
and style predator it could have
borrowed the tone it's final of the mega
exactly they probably would have been
better movies you swap them around yeah
guys it's not disappointing it's
entertainingly bad I was I was I was
amused like I only really got born in
the last 20 minutes but other than that
I wasn't bored it's not good
like I think two out of five is a fair
rating because it's and a half on a good
it's not a good movie but it's at least
entertaining and and depending on what
your expectations are for a movie like
this you might have a perfectly fine
time alright guys well did you love the
predator did you hate it where would you
rank this in the franchise are you
actually disappointed what did you if
you're disappointed by this one you must
be disappointed every time holding on to
your copy of the we didn't know how good
we had it you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation and click that
notification bow the subscribe buttons
are broken you can check us on patreon
we've got TV show reactions q and A's
more importantly false in the Stardust
app we post plenty over there post
pretty much daily would love to have you
I don't know starting Stardust follows
by